Broadway has always held a very special  place in my heart and that's one of the  things I talk about I just take a moment  to say you know of all musical  influences Broadway was a big part of it  musicals were and that sort of creating  through music and staging uh you know  it's different than a concert I go into  concert we woo we lose our minds we play  up songs down and you know and I've done  that for years this is this is different  much more intense much more  intricate and it's a lot of fun because  at this point in my life I have done  many many things I have achieved many of  my dreams and I need to have things in  front of me that I find scary and uh  intense and this is scary and intense  and it really fills that so yes as a  Cree as a Creator I wanted to make this  my art is what my life is my art and  that's why  hey thanks for watching ET Canada if you  want more queer entertainment news and  exclusive interviews be sure to  subscribe and check out these videos